الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استقيموا اعتدلوا
[Silence]
استووا استقيموا واعتدلوا
استووا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
هل اتاك حديث ضيف ابراهيم المكرمين
اذ دخلوا عليه فقالوا سلاما قال سلام قوم
منكرون فراغ الى اهله فجاء بعجل سمين
فقربه اليهم قال الا
تاكلون فاوجس منهم خيفه قالوا لا تخف
وبشروهم
بغلام عليم فاقبلت امراته في صره فصكت
وجهها وقالت عجوز
عقيم قالوا كذلك قال ربك
انه هو الحكيم العليم قال فما خطبكم ايها
المرسلون قالوا انا ارسل
الى قوم
مجرمين لنرسل عليهم
حجاره من طين مسومه عند ربك
للمسرفين فاخرجنا من كان فيها من
المؤمنين فما وجدنا فيها غير بيت من
المسلمين
وتركنا فيها ايه للذين يخافون العذاب
الاليم وفي موسى اذ ارسلناه الى فرعون
بسلطان مبين فتولى بركنه وقال ساحر او
مجنون فاخذناه وجنوده
فنبذناهم في اليم وهو مليم
فما استطا
فنبذناهم في
اليم وهو مليم وفي عاد اذ ارسلنا عليهم
الريح
العقيم ما تذر من شيء اتت عليه الا جعلته
كالرميم وفي ثمود اذ قيل لهم تمتعوا حتى
حين فعتوا عن فعصوا عن امر
ربهم فعتوا عن امر ربهم فاخذتهم الصاعقه
وهم
ينظرون فما استطاعوا من قيام وما كانوا
منتصرين وقوم نوح من قبل
انهم انهم هم كانوا
قوما فاسقين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضالين
امين
والسماء بنيناها بايد وانا
لموسعون والارض فرشناها فنعم
الماهدون ومن كل شيء خلقنا زوجين لعلكم
تذكرون ففروا الى الله اني لكم منه نذير
مبين ولا تجعلوا مع الها
اخر اني لكم منه نذير مبين كذلك ما اتى
الذين من قبلهم من رسول الا
قالوه الا قالوا ساحر او
مجنون اتواصوا به بل هم قوم
طاغون فتولى عنهم فما انت
بملوم وذكر فان الذكرى تنفع
المؤمنين وما خلقت الجن
الانس الا
ليعبدون ما اريد منهم من
رزق وما اريد ان
يطعمون ان الله هو الرزاق ذو القوه
المتين فان للذين ظلموا
ذنوبا مثل ذنوب
باصحابهم فلا
يستعجلون فويل للذين كفروا من يوم الذي
يوعدون
الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله
[Silence]
اكبر
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله جرب
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والطور وكتاب مستور في رق
منشور والبيت المعمور والسقف المرفوع
والبحر
المسجور ان عذاب ربك لواقع ما له من دافع
يوم تمور
السماء مورا وتسير الجبال
سيرا فويل يومئذ
للمكذبين الذين هم في خوض
يلعبون يوم يدعون الى نار
جهنم دعا هذه النار التي كنتم بها
تكذبون افسحر هذا ام انتم لا
تبصرون فاصلوها
فاصلوها اصلوها فاصبروا او لا
تصبروا افسحر هذا ام انتم لا
تبصرون
سواء
عليكم افسحر هذا ام انتم لا
تبصرون اصلوها فاصبروا او لا تصبروا
سواء عليكم انما تجزون ما كنتم
تعملون ان المتقين في
جنات
ونعيم فاكهين بما اتاهم ربهم ووقاهم ربهم
عذاب الجحيم كلوا واشربوا
هنيئا بما
كنتم
تعملون متكئين على
سرر
موضونه
وزوجناهم بحور عين
والمتكئين على سرر
مصفوفه
وزوجناهم بحور عين
والذين امنوا واتبعتهم
ذريتهم بايمان الحقنا بهم
ذريتهم وما التناهم من عملهم من
شيء كل امرئ بما كسب رهين
وامددناهم
بفاكهه ولحم مما
يشتهون
يتنازعون فيها كاسا لا لغو فيها ولا تاثيم
ويطوف عليهم غلمان لهم كانهم لؤلؤ
مكنون واقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قالوا انا كنا قبل في اهلنا
مشفقين
فمن الله علينا ووقانا عذاب
السموم انا كنا من قبل
ندعوه انه هو البر الرحيم فذكر فما انت
بنعمه ربك
بكاهن ولا
مجنون ام يقولون شاعر
نتربص به ريب المنون قل تربصوا فاني معكم
من
المتربصين ام تامرهم
احلامهم بهذا ام قوم
طاغون ام يقولون تقوله بل
يؤمنون فلياتوا بحديث مثله
ان كانوا
صادقين ام خلقوا من غير شيء ام
الخالقون ام خلقوا السماوات والارض بل لا
يوقنون ام
عندهم
خزائن ربك ام هم
المسيطرون ام لهم
سلم يستمعون
فيه فليات
مستمعهم بسلطان مبين ام له البنات ولكم
البنون ام تسالهم
اجرا ام تسالهم اجرا فهم من مغرم
مثقلون ام
عندهم الغيب فهم
يكتبون ام يريدون
كيدا فالذين كفروا هم
المكيدون ام لهم اله غير
الله سبحان الله
عما
يشركون وان يروا كسفا من
السماء ساقطا يقولوا سحاب
مركوم فذرهم حتى يلاقوا يومهم الذي فيه
يسعقون يوم لا يغني عنهم كيدهم شيئا ولا
هم
ينصرون وان للذين ظلموا عذابا دون ذلك
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون واصبر لحكم ربك انك
باعيننا وسبح بحمد ربك حين
تقوم ومن الليل
فسبحه
وادبار النجوم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله
والنجم اذا هوى ما ضل صاحبكم
وما غوى وما ينطق عن الهوى ان هو الا وحي
يوحى علمه شديد القوى ذو
مره
فاستوى وهو بالافق الاعلى ثم دنى
فتدلى فكان قاب قوسين او
ادنى فاوحى الى عبده ما اوحاه ما كذب
الفؤاد ما راه
افتنارونه على ما يرى ولقد راه نزله اخرى
عند سدره
المنتهى عندها جنه
الماوى اذ يغشى السدره ما يغشى ما زاغ
البص صر وما طغى لقد راى من ايات ربه
الكبرى افرايتم اللاه والعزا ومنات
الثالثه
الاخرى الكم الذكر وله
الانثى تلك اذا قسمه
ضيزا ان هي الا
اسماء سميت
ووها
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم ما انزل الله بها من
سلطان ان يتبعون الا الظن وما تهوى
الانفس ولقد
جاءهم من ربهم الهدى ام للانسان
ما
تمنى فلله الاخره
والاولى وكم من ملك في السماوات لا تغني
شفاعتهم
شيئا الا من بعد ان ياذن الله لمن
يشاء
ويرضى ان الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره
ليسمون
الملائكه تسميه
الانثى وما لهم به من علم الا اتباع الظ
ان يتبعون الا
الظن وان الظن لا يغني من الحق شيئا
فاعرض
عمن تولى عن
ذكرنا ولم يرد الا الحياه
الدنيا ذلك
مبلغهم من العلم ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن
سبيله وهو اعلم بمن
اهتدى ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
ليجزي الذين
ساءوا بما عملوا ويجزي الذين احسنوا
بالحسنى الذين يجتنبون
كبائر
الفواحش الذين يجتنبون
كبائر الاثم
والفواحش الا اللمم ان ربك لك واسع
المغفره هو اعلم بكم اذ
انشاكم من الارض
واذم
اجنه واذ انتم
اجنه في بطون
امهاتكم فلا تزكوا
انفسكم هو اعلم بمن اتقى
الله